this place if you're not too bad
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's all right
let's please why were you running what's
up where were you running from I'm
trying to give them some action skill
photography rather than just this yes
it's showtime here we go
game recognizes game how do you ever Top
This having a Premiere at the Coliseum
why not ever that's why you just like
sit in it and be president and go
appreciate this man yeah oh wow there's
other people here yeah we've got fans
all over there they see you they do one
way
who did you bring with you to celebrate
tonight because I mean this is pretty
darn special yeah I'm
yeah yeah just the whole the Brie Larson
team well they're they are my family
I've traveled with them more than
anybody else so it's yeah it means a lot
so this may be the end of the main Saga
like coming to the end of the main tag
well I don't know that's what I'm saying
there could be spin-offs people could
you know what's one spin-off that you
would like to see
well I mean you got to hang out with
Michelle Charlize and I and I think it
was very clear that we would love to
spend more time together
[Music]
I do I don't think we'd be mad about
anything that involved the ladies all
together I like it
foreign